good afternoon ladies and gentlemen I'll
now ask my chaplain to formally open the
meeting Heavenly Father we come to you
in time
I could afternoon everybody again just
to remind everybody protocol please when
you're speaking couldn't ensure that you
use the microphone and that you speak
directly into it but don't try to
swallow it in these a little bit further
away for us to be properly picked up
I'd like to revise we have a cameraman
here with us this afternoon
who's taking four photographs and the
some video footage of this meeting as
part of a putting together a training
program for new counselors not just here
but in other authorities
there'll be no audio recording or
close-ups it is purely to get shots to
convey the sense of the meeting you have
all been informed by email of this and
we haven't had any concerns addressed
but if anybody has any specific concerns
could they raise them now we haven't got
any hands when raising around so we'll
continue on that basis so thank you very
much and I call on the executive
director to report the list of apologies
Thank You chairman I can report that
we've had apologies from councillor
Barker councillor Giles Chancellor
Harris councillor carriage and
councillor Vaudrey thank you I now
invite members all so as to make their
declarations of any items on interest to
the meeting anybody under declarations
of interest no in which case we'll move
on to point three these have been
circulated I now seek a proposal a
second of the minutes of the meeting
held on the 25th February council mils
Thank You councillor Perry seconding it
are we agreed
thank you I'd now like to move on to my
announcements of wear just give you a
quick run-through now well I've attended
the mayor of lemmings and the Civic
Services and there is Covington a Norman
Church for those who might be interested
in strong beautiful cares once again at
the top of their form produced a
fantastic production of the Malcolm tour
which I was likely to be invited to the
Bearpit theatre has invited me to see
the [ __ ] of Enosh mom
[Music]
Sherman watch County Council John cook
had a dinner to which i was invited he
fighted me as chairman of Stratford to
make the toast on behalf of the guests
which I was very grateful for as a
Stratford therefore were able to talk
about all sorts of things to our other
district councillors and that evening
finally two nights ago I'm sorry last
Friday I want to see production little
women that second thought production
again at the bear pit theatre for those
who haven't visited either of those two
theaters I recommend them there are some
excellent productions going on that I
now invite the leader of Council
Thank You chair I have to say most of my
time over the last few weeks have been
taken up with routine business so I've
got no specific announcements although I
would say that the routine business has
been quite substantial thank you our
executive director yes it's really just
to extend thanks from the management
team and myself and David Buckland for
all those members that are not seeking
re-election just to thank you for your
service during that time thank you thank
you as well we therefore move on to 0.5
and this is a virtual thanks to retiring
counselors on screen they all are
anybody concerned about the order that
is the alphabetical order of your
surname as there is no precedence other
than that but what is 14 people a huge
number and their experience and last
will be significant when the council
resets along with those members who are
elected on the 2nd of may I'd like to
point out that we are losing 3 former
chairman comes for Atkinson councillor
brain and councillor Gettys we're losing
to former leaders Stephen gray and of
course Chris st. who is a leader not
once but twice I'm going to call on the
leaders of the two groups who will be a
far better position to talk about those
councillors retiring but as a chairman
I'd like to thank all those councils for
their huge support that they have given
the council during I think in some cases
hazel 26 years
would that be correct I think a
fantastic contribution to this community
while Stratford district and there are
many other very long serving men de
tousser as well so thank as behalf you
know as chairman I'd like to thank you
I'll hand over that now to the leader
Thank You chair I think it is very
interesting for teen counselors standing
down out of 35 the new council after the
elections will feel very very different
from this one the loss of experience and
expertise will I think be keenly felt
especially as regardless of the results
of the election we are going to have to
hit the ground running I'm not going to
go through every individual that would
just take me a long time but I would
like to space pay specific tribute to
three councillors my comments will be
brief
Chris st. who served as leader on two
occasions member of the Council for 21
years
contribution over that time was from
surprisingly very significant and his
retirement is well-earned Peter Morris
who has served on the council for 23
years has also spent a considerable
period as leader of the Opposition his
effectiveness in that role as being
unfortunate
I should say that having an effective
leader of the Opposition is important
and his interventions will be missed
and finally Steven third-world served as
a counselor for 15 years
Stevens impact will carry over into the
new council because he's been
instrumental in shaping the induction
and training program for councils for
new counselors I thank you for that
Steven but to all those who are leaving
the council can I just say thank you for
all your efforts and I wish you the very
best for the future whatever you may do
Thank You Cosimo's
I know it's worth a story of my life
cheering uh sure we try to be very brief
because again I give my best wishes to
all those counselors who are retiring
all of whom I believe have made a
substantial contribution to the work of
this council probably much underrated by
the general public to chairman what is
involved in being a counselor as some of
the new counselors mother at fight
surprise I just wanted to pay tribute to
Hazel Jim who on your list was the
longest-serving member to retire you
know at first met Hazel when I was
canvassing in Studley in the 1990s it
became very quickly apparent that
everybody in every door I knocked on new
hazel she was mrs. studly she's worked
wonders for suddenly over the years
quite literally put it on the map all
that remains to be done in study as far
as I can see chairman is a renovation of
the co-op site and I have to warn you if
it's not done soon hazel will be back to
haunt you 28 years hazel you served as
leader of this group for which I'm very
grateful I think above all you'll be
remembered as an excellent example of
what a local councillor can achieve for
their area so thank you indeed
hazal for 22 years ago a new manager
over the years he has become a friend
and the support it didn't take me long
to realize that this was a man of
integrity and principled with an
understanding of local politics which
was based on honesty knowledge and
awareness of course I'm sure you'll
recognize that I'm talking about Peter
Moss at classes and committees he was
always present
and calmed matter what was being
discussed bringing the quality of
incisiveness to any discussion no matter
how the other side approached him or
attacked him it was always the smile and
the twinkle in his eyes that rendered a
pleasant response perfectly true if you
watched him incisive it is equality many
of us wish we had a lesson we would all
take to leader Pete was also committed
to Residence no matter what their
problems were he would pursue their
personal issues in the best way he could
directly with those that had less I
learned as a health service manager when
approached by Peter to help him resolve
a health issue of one of the residents
yes I remember it well what mattered to
Peter was the needs of residents it does
not really care about what somebody else
thinks about him all that matters is the
resident he believes no act of kindness
and I think to a degree we all believe
this however small is ever wasted
helping the life of one person helps the
community I think that is absolutely
true Amelie finished it is the community
that Peter serves which is the great
deal of empathy recognizing their needs
fighting whatever battle needed to be
fought that volunteering your time is
and effort is worthwhile I would like to
say thank you for contributing it
swallowing time to the council and to
the Liberal Democrat Party and
continuing the liberal thread
I quote something I read many years ago
or somebody said it to me are not
absolutely sure but I think it sums up
Peter we make a living by what we get we
make a life by what we give and I
honestly think giving is his
characteristic so thank you thank you
very much I'm not likely to be called to
speak again one of the things I would
like to do after after being here quite
a long time it's to thank the staff
because if anybody deserved to fight
they most certainly do their help
through through many thick and thin
times told me when I was being stupid
told me when I wasn't being stupid that
alone is worth a million acknowledge and
appreciate the comments you've made I'm
just gonna read out the number of years
everybody served but clearly some people
continued through with other roles in
other councils so we had George accents
and 21 years Mike Breen seventeen Molly
Giles for my kisses nine years Steven
gray 14 years Moore's house eight years
Simon Norton four years Peter Moores 23
years Dave Rich's five years Chris 821
years
Stephen farewell 15 years Robert Vadra
seven years Kris Williams 21 years and
hazel
sorry hazel 28 not 26 so I'm sure we all
would like to propose a vote those who
are not retiring would like to propose a
vote of thanks to those who are retiring
can I have a proposal for that thank
your cuts are Perry absolutely
the under seconded by the leader sorry
oh no he's not a time so I'll disconfirm
are we are we agreed with that voter
Thanks
I'm sure we are thank you very much by
moving on public participation and at
this stage we receive questions for the
pub from the public there has been one
question raised by remember the public
cops of the question and the answer have
been circulated to all persons their
attendance mrs. Chaddock mr. chote
you've received an answer to your
response that's your question do you
have a supplementary question could you
come forward news of Micra and then
please there's one on this table over
here
can everybody hear me do I have to get
lower okay [ __ ] mr. chairman you've not
seen me here in this position before
I've never attended the council meeting
or asked the question so I hope you're
going to cut me a bit of slack here I've
done my best to to follow the protocols
conferring with your office your
political office and so on and so forth
but I'm here because we're at a very
serious point if you look at my question
you can probably gather the subject
matter we've got David Attenborough
going around the world whilst there's
still breath in his body to implore the
human race to act at this time we've got
young Rita Thunder burger though that's
not how she pronounces her name but we
do I think we've probably heard of her
the young school child sixteen year old
from Sweden who's going around she's
coming to London this month later this
month to meet with leaders and we've got
school our own school children out on
the streets about this issue that's
unprecedented in my lifetime I'm 58
that's never happened as far as I know
so it's a very very serious subject and
I hope you don't feel like you need to
cut me short and go to the question I
will because because because I asked the
question and I asked that it could be if
possible answered by as many people who
are able to answer it as possible it's
been answered by one councillor and I
was wondering if there was any way
beings we have just less than eleven and
a half years to respond
we can't wait 11 years and then respond
we have less than eleven half years to
actually turn this around we're on
course to miss our carbon targets the
leadership that we're getting from
central government is not exactly
signifying that this is a priority so
the purpose of me asking if you would
consider declaring a climate emergency
council level would be that it would
push the cap that the central government
to to take this more seriously 54 now
councils around the country have
declared a climate emergency and why why
couldn't Stratford perhaps consider
being the 55th so I was wondering mr.
chairman if there was any way that we
could get other councillors here
assembled today to respond to my
question and give us some reasons as to
why they might not support and vote in
favor of a motion to declare a climate
emergency instructor prevailing the you
know you had a response from the leader
to your initial question which actually
raises those issues it would not be
appropriate to have a a straw poll on
this occasion I'm pretty sure the legal
adviser on my left confirm that it's not
cause it'd be constitutionally we cannot
do that but if you wish to ask the
leader to respond to your second request
I'm sure because Jefferson on behalf of
all councillors up as the leader of this
council would be happy to respond Thank
You chair I have to say that I
personally take the threat from climate
change exceedingly seriously just
looking at some of the data which is
actually quite worrying anyone mean
growth in carbon dioxide emissions is
now around two and a half parts per
million per annum that's accelerating
current levels stands at 412 that's
getting pretty high the critical issue
is going to be how we manage the
transition and that is going to be
really really important
I think one of the big threats is we
cannot afford the progress being made on
emissions reductions to stall it was
very interesting commenting a book
called collapse by Jared Diamond written
about 15 years ago and actually one of
the biggest threats to tackling climate
change is democracy that may sound very
strange but the interesting thing is
that given the scale of transition it's
going to be how people will accept it
and I think that is going to be one of
the key challenges for us all I will go
back to when I said I personally think
this is a very very serious threat in
most cases I think it's underestimated
so I hope from that point of view you
are somewhat reassured about the
attitude the new council may take thank
you
this shall I'll go stuck together again
there's normal procedures I'm good just
ask members are we agreed with the
consent with the issues that our leader
has just raised that we do share a
concern on climate change and I think we
all are very aware of the issues and
that they need to be resolved speedily
are we agreed Council on those items
[Music]
thank you thank you
perhaps so that it's not a formal notion
and it carries no weight in terms of
anything moving forward right thank you
I now call upon the header page service
to present a revised physical balance
calculation this follows a number of
changes since we last met I think
chairman so on what best you should have
in front of you the new political
balance this calculation has been made
following some changes to the political
makeup these changes are in effect from
very short period from this council
through to the next ATM and have been
made in consultation with the leader
portfolio holder and group leader of the
Opposition in terms of the
representation on the various committees
so I ask you to consider the political
balance Thank You Council as you've got
the revised calculation in front of you
does anybody wish to raise any items
about that or are we agreed
to move forward on that basis
thank you very much I now move on to
point eight which is updates
Constitution and I'll call the leader
council to present this report Thank You
chair very briefly the proposed changes
to the Constitution are set out in item
eight are minor there really are a case
of the Constitution evolving to cope
with issues as they arise one thing in
particular is the importing 134
situation rules where the ward member
agreed with the office of recommendation
to refuse an application but differed on
the grounds for refusal the changes dish
to make sure that if both people are
agreed on a refusal then it can be
refused regardless of the fact that they
differ on the reasons so with that can I
ask that the proposed changes to the
Constitution are set out in the
appendices to the report we approved for
immediate adoption
Kelson was I'm not sure I entirely
understood what the leader was saying
there I assume there is if there's a
disagreement on reasons for refusal all
reasons put forward will be recorded as
reasons for refusal but my concern is
chairman is if the difference of opinion
between officers and the reward member
as to why something should be refused
it's important in my opinion that the
ward member has a say in those reasons
for refusal if the planning officer does
not agree then I believe it should go to
committee chairman were well aware of
how a number of developers are coming
forward and testing reasons for refusal
and they're doing that in the hope that
the Tribune and supply will disappear
and that they can come back having
established what the reasons for refusal
are we must not shortchange ourselves on
reasons for refusal chairman so I hope
my interpretation is correct there
that if a member puts forward a recent
disagrees with the planning officer all
reasons will be included in the refusal
notice second point gems are may very
briefly page 39 Chairman's paragraph B
at the bottom of page 39 the head of
planning and consultation of the
chairman of relevant planning committee
believes the application has generated
significant public interest I think
chairman we need to be careful about how
narrowly we sometimes interpret this we
had the bishops and 500 application
recently sorry coming up am i okay to
carry on thank you we had the bishop and
500 application chairman where the
intention on reserve matters was to
delegate this to planning officers and
although it has now been decided that it
will go to committee for which I'm
grateful there was initially
considerable resistance to that chairman
even though there was considerable
public anxiety in my opinion any
development of 500 houses chairman ought
to go before a planning committee I do
not believe residents will ever
understand how something of that sheer
size could be delegated to officers for
this session even if it is on reserve
matters only that's my only other
concern Shepherd about these proposed
amendments thank you
yes thank you I think your point about
reasons for refusal is well made I also
take onboard your point about large
developments having to go to planning
committee councillor Saint Chairman
approximately 12 months ago councillor
Jefferson assumed the leadership of this
council and declared he was going to be
very different from his predecessor
which was me I don't see particular
signs where he has been different
because I bequeath to him a very Council
in good health we just had a wonderful
peer review and everything was regarded
with a fine degree of esteem but what
we've had in the five or six meetings of
council this year he's fiddling about
with the Constitution we've had little
changes here and there every single
council meeting and that's one thing
where I think there can be a difference
because three years ago mr. Grafton and
I am one or two other members of this
council sat down and we did a major
review of the council also in my final
year as leader I made a major review of
the leader statement to put things in
what I thought was the proper shape as
required by law yet we seem to have this
continual fiddling about with the
Constitution as a consequence now I'm
not happy with this at all I agree with
councillor Morse that the effectively
and I'm glad the leader agrees as well
so perhaps we can have a modification to
the proposals before us because of that
degree of you
Timothy round this room but if we want
to actually achieve anything in this
council we want to stop fiddling around
with the rules and get on with doing
something purposeful and that is
building on the good work that my
administration did and developing our
aura from that I'm not saying that what
the new administration has done has
effectively been ineffective I think a
lot of it has been effective but it's
where they've continued in the same vein
as I left off and that's important and
we decided on changes to the
Constitution basically in two tranches
and we've had five different sets of
modifications ever since fiddling about
with it from one end to the other and I
think that is very very bad practice for
a local authority Thank You chairman
Pemberton
is that better can I start again really
okay so the changes the Constitution
reflects the process of continuous
improvement and no one in this cabinet
and no one in this building can possibly
argue that that is the way to go to
ensure that we continue to move forward
and deliver good services in the best
way possible
turning to Bishop ttyn first of all I
would say that there is no intention in
terms of the public interest for us to
be narrowly drawn here bishops is
actually quite that probably the example
that proves the rule in the sense that
bishops and went through its outline
application that was then one of the
very first member officer and public
resident steering group set up which
works really effectively to bring
forward changes and details of the
detailed scheme to the extent that by
the time we got to the application being
heard for the detailed matters and the
number of objections received was around
the 20 mark and the vast majority of
those were talking about the principle
of development which is the decision
that had been made at the outline stage
so this was a this was an application
that had gone through a robust process
where by and large it seemed that all of
the stakeholders were keen and it was on
that basis that initially it was felt
that it could be determined by officers
under delegated powers however
councillor Morse in his usual and
inevitable style made a robust and
intelligent intervention alongside the
ward member councillor Vaudrey to the
chairman and the chairman of the
planning committee then took that on
board and the matter was indeed being
heard by the planning committee so the
system was and there is no need to
change any of the recommendations here
around the Constitution because the
system does work and this is one of
those examples showing that so
but did have an influence members were
able to change minds and it is
absolutely the intention for us to be
able to drive forward development and we
are we do have a five year land supply
we've had a developer who's recently
abandoned an appeal having seen our
evidence on five-year land supply we are
over delivering in terms of the new
housing delivery test so we're in the
right place but we'll ensure that the
public are alongside us with that so I
would say we're in the right place we do
the right things and we go with the
Constitution amendment as presented in
the papers without any amendment council
bonds Thank You mr. chairman
I've got a problem in fact cancer brain
spoke to me about it earlier everybody
an application in my ward for nearly 40
houses came forward but we didn't appeal
190 250 people wrote in representing 356
people which was a substantial amount in
a small village for refusal the opposite
said it would be refused starter March
and continually talking to Darryl Barker
welcome to the committee on the 3rd of
April yeah sup as they're handing down
the backward I'm in negotiation with the
applicant pardon so we are still in
limbo myself and the Parish Council to
put forward planning reasons for refusal
cs50 knee won in the respect of its
outside the village boundary 800 metres
from a shop 1.2 meters from
Kosovars miles oh sorry we need to
discuss the issue on the table and I
think to bring in specific examples
which are subject to planning is for
another place it's for the planning to
make a committee to consider this issue
that we're considering now I understand
your concern we're in the situation
where the applicant can go for non
deferment have been before weeks now
yeah we can't get the opposition there
it is it
I'm stand up concerns and I'm sure the
portfolio holder would have heard your
concerns and will be picking up and I'm
sure we'll have a conversation meter
practice meeting can I have that
assurance of counsel pemberton sorry
you're about to bring me will you will
you one deal speak to mr. walsh
immediate cuts the balance immediately
afterwards thank you thank you mr.
Barnes do you have any issues to talk
about the current notion on the table no
thank you
councillor Roth thank you I just want to
take a little issue with what councillor
person said about Bishop at 500 because
I think you'll find that it was myself
in the residence group and the
developers and the planner involved but
started this whole process years ago
without moving from the same planner is
on Bishop to 500 as in urban FIFA and
the planner will say quite openly that
if it wasn't for the hard work for
myself and the residents and the
developers who are the same developers
as Bishop and 500 if it wasn't for the
hard work
toner wimpy would have taken no notice
unless they had seen what hard work we
had put in so I just want to get a point
through there that first of all it was
way back years and years and years ago
and councilor organ will remember the
work that we did on poppy meadow and we
hoped that that would be the start of
something very good with working with
developers but it kind of
it slid away slightly but it came back
without an Heath farm and so let's you
know I quite like to take a bit of
credit for actually what happened there
thank you just just to clarify and to
give credit to to you and all the board
members who work on developments this
was the first time it had been enshrined
by a determination of a planning
committee to set up a formalized
steering group and that was what I was
referring to and that has some benefits
in sort of formalizing the process with
developers but absolutely acknowledged
the work that was done with ardent faith
and did act as somewhat of a template
and hopefully we can do it more often in
the future
canal's members to restrict their
comments to items on the table going
forward the rest of meeting this is the
format to consult on this item to
consider the changes the Constitution
and the leader wishes to come back to
some of the comments made already
just pick up the points that councilor
st. made in terms of fiddling about with
the Constitution I think the
Constitution is a living document but is
in need of continuous change to reflect
what is actually happening in the world
so I made absolutely no apologies for
the fact that we keep the Constitution
updated in terms of picking up the point
that was made in by councillor morsi the
appendix to bei i propose that there is
an amendment to the recommendation that
says in appendix bei all reasons for
objection will be included so I could I
confirm do you mean 2a or 2b
I think you actually
to aim which is to way not to be right
so the leaders comments related to 2a
where you just want to repeat your
conclusion the proposed changes to the
Constitution are set out in the
appendices to the report be approved for
immediate recommendation and in appendix
2a all reasons for objection will be
recorded because almost all you Poppi
without amendment be a thank you do we
need a proposal a seconder for that as
we are amending the proposal yes because
I assume cuts Justin you're proposing
that amendment and would I be the right
institution as the mosque in a second
that amendment right so we do have an
amended version of 2a but just to make
things absolutely clear at this point we
do actually have three amendments to the
Constitution being proposed and I think
of it simpler if we deal with them as
three separate items so there can be no
concern that we have missed anything in
looking at the three different ones so
if we go to a pen the proposal details
in appendix one relating to standing
orders we've had no comments from the
floor about this are we agreed to accept
the proposal under appendix one to amend
the Constitution
thank you right we therefore move to
appendix 2a which has now been amended
in that all reasons for refusal will be
included not just work where there is a
difference between an officer and an
elected member can I ask a clarification
will that include objection of reasons
which the Parish Council separately
might bring up I'll be seeing if all
objections are to be recorded that will
be a yes thank you on that basis are we
agreed with the amended proposal
proposed by accounts of Jefferson
seconded by Councillor Morse are we
agreed to that amendment thank you we
therefore move on to point three
appendant which is appendix to B which
relates to street naming are we we've
had no points from the floor on this no
questions are we agreed to this third
amendments Constitution thank you
therefore
we can now move on from that item on the
agenda to the independent remuneration
panel and I'd like everybody's had a
copy of the report and into the
appointment of members of the panel we
have to have a panel is renewed debate
on this item or are we agreed car at
concern Thank You chairman I've appeared
before four of these panels and never go
anywhere no matter how justified I
thought my cause was but in the
proposals here I'm not certain who or
whom appointed the panel members but
what strikes me we have got four people
who do not in my opinion appear to have
any commercial or business background
there is one chap mr. Boswell who's a
retired Qantas severe I'm not certain
what breadth of management experience he
had but I just tend to believe speaking
to the panel as I say on four occasions
and getting nowhere and finding on the
report on one occasion they spoke my
name incorrectly so they are really
professional should we not have a more
balanced membership on this panel so
that we have got someone who has had to
face the hard wall of business and
everything else which goes with it and
what I'm reminded of one of the things I
have brought up this members travelling
costs we can only do it if it's on a
formal basis ie today or
for that yet something I read a number
of years ago the bloody things aren't
working yeah a number of years ago was
that members should not be disadvantaged
in carrying out of the duties we
certainly are in that one example there
are others but my main point is I do not
believe the representation on this panel
is balanced in experience of a
commercial or business nature thank you
I think because my concern councillor
Barnes it was like George they don't
really seem to understand exactly what
to do what we do the amount of working
going to look at planning I've got a
planning application now a hundred yards
from my from my house it's across the
river 13 mile still around but I concede
from my house but they didn't appear to
be geared up knew what we were doing
lost as to how this connects didn't feel
that they were involved in what we do to
know how to come to a proper agreement
I'm right in saying that the review or
the allowance as set out at the
documentation when I first joined was
set up before the wards were enlarged to
the size they are now and therefore
there are much greater distances for
instance I took the Isobel round and it
was 35 miles just to go around my ward
so they've got to take into account plus
the cost of inks and everything else
that are involved in doing hard job
take US military what we're talking
about is not reviewing the work they're
about to do it's actually looking at the
appointments proposed and the process is
detailed out in the paper can suggested
is the lead member of that we do want to
respond to any of the council actions
concerns the independent remain
remuneration panel and we actually have
to have warm is appointed by the council
so in other words it is up to the
council whether or not to accept these
five members has been appointed for the
independent remuneration power the
details of what the independent
remuneration panel looks like are
something that obviously from what
members they are the same we probably
need to take up with them so the
question really for council is given we
need an independent remuneration panel
then are these members acceptable to
Council or not
counselor Atkinson
we come back we obviously need a
remuneration panel we are governed by
central legislation to do so I'm not
arguing about that what I am saying is
that I believe that background is not
adequate enough to address the issues of
members overheads costs travelers being
mentioned others or telephone accounts
we've got to pay all that ourselves -
about 70 pounds a month yet I have read
NIOSH I could put my hands on it that
members should not be disadvantaged in
facing costs I have in my experience to
come to the conclusion that the
composition of the existing panel is
very similar to those I appear that at
the past and therefore does not have the
right balance house Jefferson is going
to respond Thank You councillor arkinson
I think probably the only way to resolve
this is that if I propose that the
recommendations on page 41
recommendation 1 and recommendation to
actually be accepted do we have a
seconder for that proposal
we need to set the second to the council
feeling surely a retired district
district councillor should be looked at
who somebody who knows what we're in for
yes I think what we're looking for them
is council gray German I was just going
to Second Council Jefferson's proposal
what we therefore have a proposal and a
seconder for this motion and that is to
point the five names selected and
recommendation of one and again I
suggest we split this into one and two
so we have a proposal in a second effort
recommendation one I see I suspect we
should go for show of hands on this
ladies and gentlemen so all those in
favor the proposal that we accept the
five names listed in the sheets could
you write all those in favor that
proposal it's been proposed and seconded
by Councillor Jefferson
and all those against do you have any
abstentions the motion is there for
carriage but the five names proposed
under recommendation one are accepted as
the future members that recommend eight
the remuneration panel recommendation
two therefore that the panel continues
to meet on a yearly basis from a light
touch review with a major of unifor is
and I think the words later on suggests
that the review will commence in July of
this year
all we agreed on that thank you
in which case we can now move on to item
10 which is I call now upon the cusp
Emerson being a portfolio over the
planning of building services to report
on item 10 thank you very much chairman
members this item is the latest in in a
series of documents being brought
forward to create the development
requirements supplementary planning
documents this covers part II
architectural style construction and
materials and the recommendation is that
council formally adopt Sparty
architectural style construction and
materials as part of the development
requirements supplementary planning
document happy to take any questions
which I'll immediately defer to the
officers other than that hopefully
any questions for councillor Pemberton
if not only agreed to agreed on that
items Thank You Kyle Simpson moving on
to item 11 minute 808 developer crops up
from extra planning document dr. Park CD
FJ + FJ s and T I'm going to call on
that the leader to respond on this one
Thank You chair just on this there is a
revision to the recommendation and that
is that the council formerly adopts Part
C D F S&T there's a respective parts of
the development requirements
supplementary planning document and that
Council formally adopts a revised
version of part J as a respective part
of the development requirements
supplementary planning document I'm just
going to ask Constance could you explain
why we're adopting a revised revised
because part of J was actually formally
adopted before and it now needs to be
readapted
so it is very simply a technical change
a minor revision thank you guys
Jefferson you've made a proposal that
amendment or do we have a seconder to
that amendment
councillor Pemberton thank you are we
agreed to accept that as described thank
you moving on to 2012 committee reports
over the last time we have committee
reports so look forward to it and enjoy
we have the first one ordinance
committee council st. yes chairman in
their electronic form I'm more than
happy to propose the minutes of the
audience Standards Committee the draft
minutes because the committee will
approve them in
course and take any questions there from
any questions counsel said Thank You
counsel sector overview and scrutiny
committee and council Ibaka's absence
counsel fielding vice chairman sorry I
propose that needs to be accepted by the
council as a true record of the 5th 6th
of March sorry
are there any questions for the Vitamin
C comes to building no thank you
cabinet 11th of March councillor Jepsen
I ask council to receive the minutes of
cabinet held on 11th of March
any questions for the leader in this
case thank you
we therefore move on to questions and
we've had seven questions received
starting off with one kalsa wall you
received a written response comes from
off you have a supplementary question
yes I do thank you chair I've recently
met with quite a lot of the volunteers
that worked at the link and they have
some serious concerns about the welfare
the mental welfare some three clients at
the link because they've got nowhere to
go to to meet others that are in the
similar position and I just think people
falling off the edge here because
they've got nowhere to go I think we
have to be mindful of this you're not
going to get homeless people visited in
this building it's too official they're
not going to come in and I know that
Anna's going out to meet them outside
but I don't want to come along here they
need somewhere to go I personally feel
that if there were problems at the link
building
we meet them closed it down we could
have continued with some effort to put
in to solving those problems and also if
you look at the last paragraph of cosa
Pemberton's response yes the homeless
have them lowered in number which
actually just goes to prove that the
link is working which also goes to proof
that we need the link we need somewhere
for those people to go it's really
really important we cannot expect other
agencies to meet them offline if so to
speak and we just can't expect these
people to come to this building so the
sooner we get them back in the building
even if it is on a temporary basis
because I do know that there are things
coming forward but that won't happen for
at least a year and a half we need
somewhere for these people to go it's
really really important thank you
Thank You chairman very first thing at
safety reference the final paragraph
will we we're down to currently a figure
of six rough sleepers and to give some
context those numbers do banks up to a
sort of over the last few years a
maximum of perhaps twenty so it's
between six and twenty they do they do
wax and wane first thing to say is six
is six too many okay so absolutely this
authority we've absolutely committed to
doing as much as possible to eradicate
the problem of rough sleeping councilor
Ralph will will will know as we had a
discussion in the car park just across
the way the decision to close the link
arose from some operational issues and
it has brought forward the opportunity
to look at a far more integrated
solution that improves the service for
those who we are trying to get away from
rough sleeping
I'm guided by the expertise of our
officers particularly knit CAD and
Castle Ralph you will know that I met
and I repeat publicly the invitation for
you to have a discussion with the
relevant officers and if you know if you
can persuade the relevant officers that
there is a tangible benefit and value to
be had by some temporary then that's
something that I'm open to as is this
Authority but I think we can't just
reopen it just because well we were open
it what are we what is it actually going
to do and how is it going to win
how is it going to integrate with the
other surfaces and just as you'll refer
in my answer there are a number of
services that you know this is not a
removal of a service or removal of a
support this is an element of it where
we're looking then to refine exactly
what we do and how we do it and in terms
of a timeline 18 months I think
certainly the management team are to
meet on the 18 are meeting on the 18th
to consider a proposal which I think
that councillor Rove has some knowledge
of about a way forward and so I would
suggest that the timeline is going to be
significantly shorter than three months
sorry 8123
been eighteen months so I am truly
expecting us to be in a position to
bring forward and noting councillor
mosses comments about we're not all sure
whether it's looking to be here that
those of us who ever sold in this
portfolio will be bringing something
forward very quickly with you know what
we hope will be a much more effective
solution to the problem Thank You
counsel Pam stone will move on to
accounts of tragedy
Thank You chair I just like to say that
proper installation in homes there's two
things it reduces the costs to the
homeowners and it also reduces the co2
footprint of those homes in the light of
what the leader said at the beginning of
this meeting I would like some assurance
that the reduction in the water and the
support for actual energy which actually
works in this area should be reviewed as
soon as possible in the new council
because as we've actually just had a
straw poll on we're taking this very
seriously thank you because the pendulum
would you like Thank You chairman thank
you very much councillor fetch League
and you're absolutely right and I think
there's anybody in this room who does
not understand the gravity of the issue
that faces all of us who inhabit this
rock the overview in scrutiny committee
looked at sort of balance of our funding
however those things are not casting
stone we are to embark on a new
corporate strategy and clearly as as has
been said shown earlier today this
Authority is not blind to ensuring that
climate change and the impacts of
climate change is feeding to that
strategy so I think you're absolutely
right and you can have the assurance
that again whoever holds this portfolio
in after May and will clearly be happy
to look at that again
I counsel frankly number four thank you
actually surprisingly this had I had a
an email box full of people asking about
this and when I asked questions I got
two answers one was it was a wrong
dilation and another answer it was an
over-enthusiastic operator I'm very
pleased to see here
former default notice has been given i
would like an assurance that the results
from that are communicated even if I'm
not here I would still actually like to
know exactly what went wrong
and any future consequences from the
over-enthusiastic application of a
chemical Thank You counsel
all right you can to the fact that I
won't be here either well you might be I
certainly were I'm sure the officer at
the back of the room
Tony will take on board what you're
saying and you will get a response when
the inquiries being completed Council
right question number five it's
interesting to know the figures for last
year and this year and the increase that
there's been that represents a lot of
human misery but we're here today on the
radio and I might have misheard I don't
know somebody will correct me is that
they are going to abolish the section 21
evictions but not done it they're going
to do it and really we all know how long
it takes for stuff to go through
Parliament and the various committees
before it's amended if they are true to
their words and if it really happens a
quarter according to these figures
should benefit from that act thank you
thank you thank you yeah just to confirm
I I've heard the same reports as
councilor right that the Minister James
broken Shire has indicated that section
21 of action notices are going to be
ended and I think actually I you know
I'm really in support of that I think
you know there are there are not there
are good landlords I
but there are landlords out there who
will take advantage of that and again
coming back to things I've said earlier
about continuous improvement now then
this is an example I take the point that
these things can take time to wind
through in terms of legislation I'm
struggling to see what we may be able to
do in advance of that but you can be
assured that when the when the
opportunity affords itself to ensure
that section 21 is not used in that way
that will take it up and certainly I can
also give some members assurance
following conversations I've had with
Nick CAD that where we feel that
landlords are acting inappropriately we
will push back and Nick addicts I can't
share the details other than to say
somebody presented sort of in the middle
part of an afternoon having been thrown
out and they were back in their
accommodation the same evening as a
result of the work by by our officers in
pushing back on on these things so just
to give that assurance that whilst
section 21 repeal may take some time
we're still going to be pushing hard for
for all of our residents Thank You
councilmember some coastal rights you
know got your second you know
supplementary questions in which we go
to number seven council moss
this is your last fling customer right
thank you thank you very much it comes
from global Saint council more so not
having a supplementary can I thank
council awards for being architect
archaeologically relevantly and for
thanking you for not finishing off with
the flourish but may I actually thank
him for all of his all of his
intelligent questioning calling us all
to account though and good luck for the
future but we now move on to point 14
which is questions to leader do we have
any questions for the unit
thank you I just wanted to actually go
come back to a question that Council of
Australia in the written questions I
just want to ask the leader if he's
going to make sure that they you need to
make every effort for the link project
to make sure that the services are not
provided from here they're not provided
from this office any service I think
that's really important because it's
easier it's easy for officers to
actually deal with people here however
people with it with situations that
they've got with mental health problems
addictions using the council offices is
a barrier and the other question would
be in many respects people with
situations that live quite quite chaotic
lives they are dealing with addictions
or had addictions but they're actually
kicking the habit but they're always
just one just one small step away from
falling back down and so I think the
council needs to be really mindful about
the an alternative service when it does
come on string needs to be coming on
stream in a matter of weeks and not
months so I just hope those I think the
longer it's left and there's a vacuum
and avoid
they service for four people in these
kind of situations the worse it's going
to get very very quickly and that's just
a warning to the council that they need
to take on board Thank You councillor
phytate I agree with your first
statement on the second one the speed
with which we can respond it depends on
what facilities we can actually gain I
fully understand the need for speed it
is what he's actually practical and we
fully appreciate the point you are
making about how easy it is for people
with addictions to slip back we will do
what we can and we will move as swiftly
as we can very new mind the
practicalities come off this is not
going to be popular to see leader and
the chair find it very disconcerting
that there's a member of this council
that has been on his mobile phone
virtually the entire meeting I do think
in the new council we should have some
kind of ruling because I don't believe
people can multitask
the way that some women can but I do
believe that that there should be some
ruling that all mobile phones should be
switched off are not set to silent I'm
finding it disconcerting and I'm sure
you are as well thank you
Thank You councillor wolf I'm sure I
share your concerns about people using
social media during this meeting during
any meeting I mean it has been referred
to previously and I think probably won't
be appropriate is after meeting you
could raise that item and I think the
leader wants may come into I think here
is a very interesting point council golf
and I think it is something that we mean
we may well need to set a totally
different tone for the new council when
he
is elected house loquacious Thank You
chairman less controversial we've heard
quite a lot about the environment today
both from mr. Chadha at the beginning
the meeting and by Councillor fragile II
the beginning of my term of office I had
the pleasure of chairing the EQ CC which
is an environmental quality climate
change panel of which council frankly
was a member and I would ask the
administration that's a council in the
next term of elected office consider in
the light of what's being said here
today and agree notionally by all the
members here that that panel should be
brought back to life re instigated and
advise the authority on the way forward
through mindful environmental issues
Jefferson I think that point is well
worth considering
Thank You councillor Atkinson for many
years certainly in my career I what
under the authority that management must
manage I see that on the 23rd of January
that governance review emerging position
whatever it was had a meeting and it
said planning delegations change this
scheme of delegation to allow more
householder applications to be delegated
to officers in order to reduce committee
agenda see appendix a I haven't got that
I don't know where's gone to but
certainly speaking to one or two of the
plan officers and I say do you have to
have everything sanctioned oh yes how
long have you been with the authority
sixteen to twenty years how many of your
recommendations are refused though less
than ten percent possibly about five is
there any progress on this policy which
I believe should be introduced occurring
council Jefferson
Thank You counselor Atkinson I can't
respond immediately we're looking to eat
and our responding writing caltrak
answer your second question certainly on
the minutes of their particular occasion
I mentioned it does say 0.5 reduce
membership of J and C G from 9 to 6 I
think if I'd being listened to for about
two and a half years it should be
counselor membership from nine to six so
that we've got a balance between staff
and elected members absolutely correct
councillor Atkinson council brain did I
see your hand in relation to councillor
Rolf's
about social media that I have used my
phone today but not for social media by
a modern man I'll use my iPad regularly
now which other councillors did as well
because it would save paper I used my
phone today to look at recycling rates
in relation to question 6 which was
hazel rights question to see what the
average that I made a note of that so
that's why I use my phone today just so
you're clear thank you for that
clarification cancer brain I'm full
council elf is grateful for your
updating the position right if there are
noble questions from members to the
leader and I've not been informed of any
offensive items I think there is no more
business be conducted today council
fielding I just like to point out that
the Herald said that I was standing down
in Grove grossly overrated I've got an
apology from them but I will be standing
Thank You Elsa field in fact I'm sure a
little be grateful for that
clarification
as what their reporter is here some of
us might be here
some of us read through here all those
who will not be here I'm sure I speak
again on behalf those we know those who
are retiring but those who unfortunately
don't reappear in May until I'm half
Wallace thank you very much for your
contributions I hope your campaigns go
well and we will reconvene the new
council post the second of May and no
doubt will see many of you to the
council occasion so as a reserve or a
business I'll now close the meeting and
say thank you all and goodbye and
farewell